[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey what's going on everyone thank you
for joining me this saturday as usual
we're doing our infinite journeys art
together having a good time
uh
the last two weeks i've been custom
modeling out the entire submission the
interior of the sci-fi cockpit and this
time on this stream
it's time to texture this thing we're
going to be building master materials
focusing on surface imperfections we're
going to make it dirty we're going to
scratch it up it's going to look really
really nice so i'm excited to do that
i'm using c4d in octane but you all can
use whatever program you want as you
know
you can do this in unreal you can do
this in blender you can do this in
whatever program um so we're just going
to be kind of going over like the core
concepts of of how to do this and and
the the practices of
you know making something look legit uh
making something look scratched up i'll
probably be using a little bit of
reference as usual
and for those of you who need some
awesome uh surface imperfections i got a
whole i made an entire pack of surface
imperfections uh last year but for
this stream only i got 50 off my entire
surface imperfection pack as well as all
the other packs on my gumroad the link
is in the description you got to use the
code what's the code it's like pwn 50
off i think is what it is just copy that
and paste it into the gum road
when you check out um but it's i'm gonna
be using my surface imperfections on the
stream here so you guys can kind of get
an idea you don't have to use them
specifically you can use whichever ones
you want but i just thought you know i
get you all 50 off for this stream while
we're doing this thing so
uh let's uh let's let's hop into it
all right
so as you can see here i got octane up
and running
um it's been a minute since i've been in
octane because i've been an unreal
engine for so long
and finally now i'm like
back in c4d i'm back in octane it feels
really good
and i've just been working super hard on
modeling all this stuff all this is
custom modeled if y'all are just tuning
in and figuring this stuff out right now
with me
this is all custom modeled over the last
two weeks i've been working
average two and a half hours a day
probably um
and i've been learning a lot you know
i've been picking you know picking back
up c4d and we're gonna go through this
and we're gonna
we're gonna texture this thing
out
so
i don't quite know what i want it to
look like yet
but i do know there needs to be some
scratched metal i know there needs to be
some like painted metal with scratches
on the edges
um that kind of stuff i know there needs
to be some smudged stuff i i know there
probably needs to be
some plastic some smudged plastic and
stuff
um
so it's gonna be sweet i'm excited to
just jump into this and get going with
y'all now lighting wise
that's gonna change
a bunch until they hit final render and
to be honest with y'all i'm gonna keep
tweaking this thing until i hit final
render
for those of you who are joining this
infinite journeys challenge
we have until february 27th 11 59 pm pst
so we have just over a week we have like
eight days probably um
so
i'm excited to see what you all do we've
been getting a bunch of submissions in
it's really really cool and probably
halfway through the stream i'm going to
dive into all the works in progress that
y'all have been submitting on the
discord i'm gonna go through those and
just feature some cool stuff from the
community so
let's uh let's get started shall we
so i'm gonna go ahead and open
pureref
and this is a free program you all know
i mean y'all been here before right
so we're going to open this up
and take a look at all this stuff all
these references i've been going for
um
and i hadn't even looked or thought of
this in terms of texturing yet it's all
just been for modeling right i've been
trying to model this
as good as possible this is my plans for
the future on this thing i still have
more modeling to do but i think it's
time to get into texturing obviously
um
so yeah i'm kind of figuring this out as
we go to be honest with you all this is
the only image i pulled
the other day
for like color
reference i thought this was a cool
color this like green blue gray
kind of color
i thought it looked really cool
mixed with this orange right here
and the reds i thought that looked
really really nice
so i might try for something like that
there's also
this kind of vibe here
which
is kind of similar actually
it's a cool look i really dig this look
uh this is from the movie sunshine danny
boyle
um great move if you all hadn't seen it
yet
but there's a lot of good reference in
here this gray this is this is more i
feel like there's less color in this
but i like
this color contrast is really cool i dig
that
um notice here for the surface
imperfections look at all the dust and
the dirt and the like
all the little grime inside the cracks
and whatnot
so i'll be trying to recreate this with
a with a master material
notice all the scratches and
and dust on the glass here
right this is from inception or not
inception interstellar
so we're going to be going for that on
the windshield
um what else mad max of course yeah look
at all the
the rust and grunge here
into this like plated metal i'll
probably be doing a little bit of that
as well
um
same for this kind of rusted corroded
metal
that's really good stuff dirty
windshield
look at all the surface imperfections
here it's all about the surface
imperfections they tell a story of where
your creation has been and it brings it
truly brings it to life it's my favorite
part to be honest
um
not that i would lie about that i don't
know why i would say to be honest anyway
i'm just being silly um what else can we
reference anything else for materials
and textures the reference is always
important you guys need to reference
what you're trying to create
um you can see the cracked old leather
is a good one
um
we have carbon fiber i don't know if i'm
gonna include carbon fiber
on this one
but we'll see
we will see
it's a nice felt i'll probably have some
felt
and my render
this one's pretty dirty
nice and grimy
pretty good reference i feel like mad
max
is a great reference
because these are all pretty clean
this is super clean
let's see um
yeah this is all clean this might have
some stuff
yeah you see the dust
and whatnot
the dirt here in the corners like that's
all
really good stuff that we want to get
into
essentially i'm gonna take this as a
reference let's try and recreate this
kind of vibe
with this kind of dirt on it
and then we can go from there
all right
amazing okay
so
let's see i'm just gonna hop into a new
scene anytime i'm like creating
something um
creating something new if i'm doing like
a small model a new model or something
or if i'm creating a new material i'll
always hop into a new scene so control n
will get you into a new project
that way it just you know we're working
quickly we're working efficiently
so
let me see here let's pull up the octane
live viewer
and dock this thing
i don't know i think that'll probably be
fine for us today
something like this now we want to pull
up maybe we'll grab something here and
we'll just kind of use
one of these pieces
as our stand in
uh let's see let's figure out which
piece i'm hitting n a and b
and c
n d i'm going back and forth and a and b
and you can see the displays n a and b
and c and d and that just switches
between all your different like viewport
options
and this one's super clean like the way
it looks
uh what's a good
piece
for us to like
start messing with maybe this tv
this is probably not a bad
thing to pull
so let's find it in our scene
uh
the monitor okay yeah i'll just copy
this over
paste it in our scene
and i'm just gonna zero out
the transformation
sweet
save our scene master material and
get that live viewer popping off okay so
i have an emission
material on there i'm just going to go
and delete that i don't really
yeah maybe i won't delete it i'll just
hide the screen
itself
there we go
okay
so
um
let's get rid of
these bars shift v
and we go to back
or no not not back it's where is it
safe frames turn off safe frames
yeah
and i don't i fear there's probably a
way to do it here in octane as well
but
i am not going to worry about that right
now
okay
shift f2 will bring up your materials in
uh in c4dr25 here
and let's go ahead and create just a
base coat right so i'll double click
no i won't um i set up my custom buttons
here the way i'm doing that is uh shift
c will search anything i'm just typing
octane or you can type redshift and drag
all your materials and lights and
you know all that good stuff over onto
the right and then go to window
customization you can save it as your
startup layout or save it as any custom
layout that you want
um so you just have those things there
let's make a
octane glossy material
and apply this to
the part of this monitor that we want
let's okay let's also
alright so apply that there
apply it there
yes yes
and let's go ahead and apply it here and
i'm just going to quickly set up a
hdri
for us
now you can see how like it makes it
difficult to see our model right so i'm
hit enqueue nq will get rid of your
texture in your viewport right
so that's super easy
now
let's go ahead and set up some lighting
okay so i'm just gonna do it go super
easy on this let's make
an
hdri
environment here i'll click the
environment tag and we'll go ahead and
just load
any old
image texture okay now it's frozen
is it gonna crash
is it gonna crash
it's not gonna crash sweet
um all right let's pull up vfx
assets
boom hdris hdri haven honestly is the
best i sell hdris
and
i admit hdri haven is the weight there's
no like come on
don't even buy my hdris don't do it
just go to hdrihaven.com
let's go to outdoor
no screw it let's go indoor
uh let's just pull any one of these
and you notice how it's all blown out
like what the heck
so you're gonna click the little preview
here and just set the color profile to
linear and that's gonna smooth it out we
can also make a camera
get up in that camera camera imager
check
enable camera imager
set the gamma to
1
and it's darn bright so we can set the
exposure to like 0.2
yeah
that looks great 0.3 perhaps
that's solid yeah you can see the
reflection
in the tv monitor
so this is a perfect setup now we can
actually tell kind of what's going on
with our materials right
hey we got some super chats we got
brendan huskin hey clint when do i need
to submit my render for the competition
good question brandon so
uh you're gonna have to submit february
27th by 11 59 pm pst so that's gonna be
next saturday right we got one more
stream one more live stream next
saturday right and then uh basically the
day after the sunday
you have until 11 59 pm
pacific standard time on that next
sunday to get your submission in if it
comes in a minute late y'all aren't
gonna be
you just you just can't win at that
point you know like you can't win any
prizes you can't win the top 100
um so
uh
yeah don't don't be those like handful
of 40 to 60 people that always submit
late it's a stressful thing
don't do it we got another one
we got johnny boz in the house
mustache just no like
no message just a straight like
just a mustache johnny boss it's been a
long time it's good to see ya or at
least see your face
um
last time i saw you we played mario kart
at vidcon
and um
i i won't say any more gruesome details
i i won't get into it because it's it's
quite brutal
and you know we got kids here in the
stream and i
i i don't want to get into it like that
you know that's it's pretty bad so
johnny boz good to see you man shout
outs i wish i had a mustache
um
so i appreciate your e-mustache that you
just sent over
good stuff good times all right um
let's choose the color of our
thingy here let's go to pure f we want
to reference
this color right here it's a awesome
color i dig it so we'll go to diffuse
i'm always up in that node editor
and we got a color picker do we even
have a color picker
hmm
there was a color picker
but it went away immediately
oh it's also over here what
what do i have to hold it down
that's weird
that's very strange
and very annoying
because i want this color right here
i'll do my best i'm a colorblind man but
i will do my best to find this color
it's probably somewhere
in
this territory
i don't know is that
is that a thing at all how how close is
that
oh here's another thing i love doing so
i like to put my
node editor
up in here so i can just go back and
forth
and navigate this way you know
all right yes obviously i need to fix my
i don't know what is that issue that's a
normals issue or a
unwrapping issue
it's all good though
we're gonna get past it
all right a little bit more on the blue
side huh
something like that
no
yeah a little bit more blue huh a little
bit more blue
um
hey there we go
sotomonte in my ear just giving me nice
little tips um i'm using this eyedropper
on the right
and i'm just pulling
pulling from there that looks awesome
i'm down for that okay so it's not very
reflective or rather it is reflective
but it's rough so i'm gonna go to
roughness and i'm probably gonna use
a surface imperfection here
our first one
so
let me navigate to the surface
imperfections
i'm gonna go
with 2k
imperfections right now because i don't
think i really need
anything larger than 2k
um and i'm gonna pull from the screen
smudges probably
the smudgy monitor
let's give that a shot we're going to
use this for the dirt as well
but let's see what we can do here
pipe that into the roughness channel
and bam
already looking sweet
so i want to wrap this properly so
projection
node i want to set it to box
and here let me show you what this does
right click we're going to solo it
you can see how
janky that looks right because i didn't
unwrap anything
i'll just edit the box
and
it kind of just cleans it up a lot right
so i'm going to go to transform and
we'll scale it down like point two
obviously that's a massive fingerprint
so probably 0.05
feels about right
awesome
we'll unsolo
because now we got our size correct
now what i'm gonna do is you see how
these reflections are super crisp here
right i i wanna take the black level
right here
and turn it gray and the way i'm gonna
do that is just drop in an octane
gradient node
and if i can find it
bam i'll pipe it right in the middle
there okay so if i solo this
and i take the black and i say the black
is half gray
boom and we unsold you can see
it smooths it out a lot more right which
gets us closer to our
reference it's not as
reflective right it's more more rough
um
let's see so i might take that down a
little bit
and then take our white
no the white needs to stay up
cool and like these little imperfections
here
or these errors in the geometry i'm not
going to worry about for now
i can fix the ones that are janky a
little bit later okay
um
now
there's some scratching in this
material i'm looking at like
there's also inconsistency in the color
too
so
you you notice it it's it's not just a
pure tone there's actually
subtle differences this is like a
classic trick that i love to do
and i'll show you real quick
basically
what i'm going to do
is in the diffuse tab
we can actually
use um
it's the best way to do this
so we're gonna do a noise
octane
noise is fine
and we want the same deal so the
projection is all jacked right
so we'll do a projection node and with
noise i always go to
oh there's some new ones here
but x y z to u v w
and i always uh crank the contrast
just so i can see like what we're doing
and then i'll make a transform node
and scale it down
that's probably good
0.15 yeah okay
and then i will
let's see
i think
purlin is yeah the best for this
in a very subtle
subtle
change here if i go zero
okay so there's still some stuff there
so i'll mess with that with the gradient
but now what we want to do
if i remember correctly it's been a long
time i want to change the color of these
things
so i'm going to do that with
actually with the gradient with the
octane gradient i'm gonna pipe that
right in
and we'll say
black is actually
that original color we chose
yep okay so the black
let's go ahead and color drop that
original color
the white
we all we will also color drop the
original color and then slightly shift
it so i'm gonna shift it to more of like
a brighter
grayer
maybe a touch
towards green
so now there's a very subtle
difference in this if i if i crunch it
you can really tell right there
and i'm probably gonna switch this
around
and we can even go a third color if we
want but i think we can just leave it
here for now
that just gives it a a touch of detail
right
um so we have our roughness on here
let's go ahead and add a bump
so for the bump
i wanted to give it like a coated
painted sprayed texture so i'm gonna
bust out
another
noise i'll do octane noise
and same deal right the projection is
going to be
we're gonna do this a lot it's gonna be
xyz to uvw for noise right and then
transform of course will bust out
and the transform is really
kind of the thing that does it because
it's a very small scale so 0.01
yeah so that looks horrible
but it's all good
um let's go ahead and change our type to
make sure we're getting the correct type
uh more looks more like a leather
turbulence
let's go omega 0.8 and omega is just
going to kind of make it more fine and
break it up now when you do this it
takes away the the the sheen from it so
we got to go real subtle with it
all right and now i'll scale this down
point oh
and it's going to be viewed from a
distance
that's the true like tell of like how
it's going to look right
and that'll determine
how our bump looks now it's really
intense
and we want to we want to chill it out
so what i do is a multiply node boom
i'll put a multiply node in there
and then a float node
and the float value is going to
determine our strength
so if it's zeroed out
it's going to be as if there is no bump
right
and if i go to 1 it's going to be like
it was before so i'm going like 0.1
0.01
so there's a very subtle bump on this
thing to give it some texture i think i
can scale
i don't think it needs to be scaled down
anymore
it's a super subtle effect
but it gives it some like
some grit to it right
you see what i mean you can kind of tell
what i'm going for right it's like that
metal
surface now this is more of a plastic
so we can roll this off
if we don't want that that feeling so
0.01 can go to just
0.0025
that's a little bit more chill
all right so we'll we know that's our
bump all right we know that this is
breaking up our reflection
and i think it can go even more
i can really walk it up there
so that actually is a bit closer to
to the reference now
we got scratches and we got um
we have the dust and the dirt right so
we're gonna do two scratch passes and
probably two dirt passes the scratch
pass you can see is really on the edges
here
right and we have all these like worn
edges here
that we're going to get scratched up
and then we actually have
scratches on the surface itself
so
let's go ahead
and give that a
shot so
i'm trying to do this all from one
material too as opposed to a mixed
material
all right
so
there's a few different layers a few
different ways we can do this
let's think about how we want to do the
scratches so we are scratching away at
the paint and revealing paint underneath
so there's probably
two versions of this
there is like a primer just like uh the
mega the mug wump one is saying um
yes there's a primer so you're gonna
prime it with a certain color and you're
going to scratch away the the top coat
to reveal that primer coat and then if
you scratch it even harder you can
actually see
the um
the scratched metal
underneath all right so that's what
we're gonna go for let's start with the
primer coat all right
so the primer coat will be a different
color very similar to how we did this
like separate color situation here it'll
just be a little different color
and
how are we going to do this
i think it's going to be a
mix
node
so let's bust out a mix node
bam
that's not going into our mount that's
going into texture one
texture two
will be our new color so that's gonna be
an rgb spectrum
and let's go ahead and just to get us in
the ballpark let's select that base
color again
and then let's go ahead and really like
let's go ahead and chill it out
and maybe i can reference
a new bit of color
in the actual reference here so let me
see
how different this will be
we're trying to get this as bright as
possible
there we go cool all right so this is
our new color
which is it's a subtle difference but i
think we'll tell once we plug in our
amount so our amount we're going to use
another surface imperfection from my
pack
once again
50 off during this stream y'all can get
it on the gum road the link is in the
description the promo code is pwn 50 off
on checkout
just for this stream only
um
so let me bust out one of those uh i
made some new ones actually at camp
mograph um
maybe those are gonna be good
for what we're doing but let's maybe
start with the og pack let's go textures
2k
we don't need anything like i can
honestly could be doing 1k
screw it let's just do it
and we have a bunch of scratches
let's try this first one i want
something subtle i don't want anything
crazy
we'll pipe that into the amount
and you can't even tell what's going on
let's do some operations here let's
right click it solo it
okay cool so we're getting some stuff
but let's set the projection once again
we're gonna go
uh box projection and it's way too large
so we'll go to transform and we'll scale
it down to probably 0.00
0.1
yeah 0.1 looks pretty darn good
to me
okay
now let's disable that
now our
coat is probably a little too similar so
i'm gonna
make it a bit more pale
there we go
that feels good and then we can change
the gamma on this to really open it up
to get more of that scratch in there
that's looking cool so now we have this
set up we can like replace it with
different
with different textures
and see what it looks like so
let me just start dropping in some new
ones um
all right this is my second uh
most scrap i guess a little intense
it's a little intense not really the
scratches i'm going for so i'm going to
go to the ones i made for camp mograph
i think these ones are on the patreon
right now and also if you all are trying
to get all my stuff forever and ever
it's on the patreon all the packs i have
on gumroad are on patreon plus a bunch
more stuff so
i had some photo scans up there and
whatnot
um all right so let's go to oh god these
are only
massive i
hadn't i don't think i've uh
broken these up
into like 1k 2k 4k i got to do that
but let's see
if these scratches are any better
yep a lot more
subtle
way more subtle okay
let's try
some of these maybe
those are probably pretty good
let's give these like long streaky ones
a shot
i feel like i'm going to
take my gradient here i'm seeing this a
little much i think i'm gonna just scale
this up so 0.15 let's go to like point
four
yeah that feels a little bit better
and then i have some really intense
scratches
maybe these are probably the way to go
yeah it's more like micro scratches and
stuff
and i think i'll scale this up
that feels good to me okay so i'll roll
with that and then
let's go ahead and work on our
edge scratches so i want to chip away at
the edge of this thing right
and that's going to utilize a dirt note
all right so we have
all of this right now just piped into
our diffuse pass
i'm just going to clean this up a touch
and i'm going to
unpipe it
and
pop in a dirt node
cool now you can see it's kind of in the
crevices
it's making a mask so whatever is in the
crevices is really dark
we want the opposite
so we are going to invert the normals
all right now this is looking a little
little janky
10 strength
0.1 radius there we go there we go
so now it's on the edges right
let's go five strength
point five really
0.2 radius
0.15 radius 0.1 radius
sure okay
um
spread i think we can
okay that doesn't go higher than one
distribution
if we max that out
all right let's just keep that at one
for now
all right let's see what we can do with
this so we're basically gonna use this
as a uh
as a mask
to differentiate as an amount
essentially to differentiate between two
different colors and it's going to be
these colors here so
i'm going to use another mix texture
this is when it starts to get crazy
let's use another mixed texture
um
[Music]
boom
this will be
the the amount that will absolutely be
the amount
all this stuff we just did before is
gonna be our texture one
and then
this guy right here
will also pipe into texture too because
that's what we're trying to chip away
and reveal
so the way um
i test this out
is
because it's hard to tell what's doing
what right now
so i'm gonna just control drag this
pipe it in to texture two
and make it something obvious like
yellow
so we know that's not working correctly
i think we need to flip it right so we
need to say that's texture one and this
is texture two
that's working properly now great got it
so let's get this looking good
this is a very obvious very dramatic
version of what we're trying to do
but at least we're able to see you know
and then we can switch it out for the
more subtle version
and of course once we set up this master
material we're gonna be able to switch
out all the colors and
and this will be like
again yeah it'll be the master material
for all the different
parts of our spaceship that we're trying
to texture
i'll make a steel one as well
like a scratched steel
and maybe a plastic one or something as
as needed
okay
so
we want to crunch this
down there's a few things that we need
to do right so we need to break it up so
it's not uniform we want it to be like
chipped in certain areas not
every single edge
and i also
that's probably the main one that's the
main one right so let's start with that
i believe this is when it starts to get
a little hairy
and a bit confusing so
let me focus here let's see
all right so it's this
dirt node this is the dirt node that
needs to be broken up so i think it's an
add i'm going to add something
to this dirt node and i'm going to add a
octane
noise
node so i'll drop that in
there
wow okay ignore that for now it's gonna
be insane
we're gonna need
here's what i'll do i'll delete that
i'ma control drag this because it's
basically already set up
i'll pipe it in texture too
solo it
i'm going to
set the contrast to a hundred
and maybe i'll scale it down to like
point three
and let's just see if this is doing
anything
all right it's not looking good let me
try and switch the order
i don't think that's doing what we need
it to do
i swore it was an add but
maybe it's a multiply
maybe we take the strength 10.
bring the radius down a touch
i'ma try the um the add again because i
really feel like it's supposed to be the
add
yeah
let's give the ad a shot
one more time
hmm
you know that should be working right
you see how it's just in those areas
right there
let's try and crunch it
so we'll do uh
octane gradient
oh wow okay just that alone
did it
interesting okay
so we can control that now we can crunch
it
all the way down
and that kind of opens it up a little
bit
or we can do the opposite and
remove it
so
let's go ahead and adjust these details
let's go to like five
on the strength maybe two on the
strength
five on the strength works
radius let's try point one all right so
the radius is being weird i think that's
just because my modeling skills are all
jacked
0.1.05
0.06 i'm just going to open this up
until it works let's try point one and
then crunch it with this gradient
yeah
yeah that's working
that looks awesome
right and then this is kind of adjusted
based off of this this noise right so we
can
we can like tighten this up
remove some of the contrast
maybe like 75 or something
and we can scale it as well so we can go
to transform and go 0.5
so it's like a little larger but i think
0.3 didn't look half bad you know
um
i wonder if there's a way to have it
spill over the edge a little bit so we
can go like
radius 0.2
0.12
and we can crunch it more
you know that works
and you can just mess with your octaves
they're taking it low like
spreads it out makes it not as chippy
and then we can also go like max on the
octaves
to really make it chippy and like
almost feel kind of corroded
we can go one on the omega that's really
gonna get in there and make it like a
fine
but that let's go ahead and just change
this color back
so i'll remove this color
and replace it
with that scratched color and we can
even
just keep going with this we can make it
brighter
and in this gradient it's looking like
you can probably open it up a touch
strength 10.
sweet so it's starting to
to look a little bit more jacked up
and i'm digging it
i really like that look
now the scratches might be a bit much so
we can go to the actual scratch texture
and we can bring the gamma up and that
will remove
a bit of the intensity
on that
sweet okay
so
now what i want to do is chip away
once again with the same dirt node
but i'm going to reveal a like the base
coat this the actual like steel
underneath
um
and then we'll do the same but with some
some dirt as well
so i think
we're probably looking pretty good here
on this material
as just a base coat right we can take
this bump back up to um
0.01
maybe
so that feels more like a metal than a
plastic right there
but it's looking pretty sweet
and i can apply this to these screws as
well so let me let me apply that to the
screws
let's do
where are these guys
these guys here okay cool let me group
that
screws
is all the detail going to be visible in
the final shot absolutely
absolutely
i'll control drag this
to the screws
awesome
awesome
and it looks like these guys
on the side here can just be
brought in a little bit closer
yeah i know it's there but which one is
it there we go here we go
sweet
awesome all right
so now let's make that steel
material
um
grayscale gorilla has some really good
stuff we could
look at their plus library
and maybe go to like
everyday materials
and we can pull one of these perhaps
or make our own we can figure it out
maybe a corroded iron or something
to be sweet
i'll just drag this in
and
apply this
to the front face
now of course you notice the the
horrible
uh normals here and the the unwrapping
and i guess it's just bad topography
but
i'm lazy
and i fix this
let's see i fixed this by not fixing my
geometry
but by putting different projection
nodes
on these materials now i know there's a
way to like select all of these
and we can go add to selected projection
bam all at once took me forever to
figure that one out
i'll set that to box
wow yeah still looks janky
but it's okay it's not gonna be over
this entire thing we'll go point one on
the scale
0.05 on the scale
sweet and this this uh
this metal feels about right to me
i don't know if we need all of these
different uh textures though oh here's
here's a trick to keep your vram down so
i'm going to select all these bits that
are
black and white
so my metallic
my roughness
right and i'm going to set
these to float and if you notice
if you can see this
my used vram is 1.94
but if i set these two textures to float
it'll go down to 1.85
so the more often you can do that it's
going to save you vram for sure
for sure for sure
all right
um
so we'll just say that's our base metal
right now
and i'll just go ahead and take it off
there
and we're gonna make a mix
material right so i have this
little button here or you can go to
objects
or sorry materials create
mix material all right so we'll go in
here to this mix material
we want to mix between
this base material that we had set up
if you shift-click the actual like root
it'll drag everything
so
that'll be material two
and then we have this iron corroded
that'll be material one again shift
clicking like the root
node here
material one
and i'm going to use that dirt node that
we had set up
to distribute these right now they're
just being 50 50 it's a 50 50 blend
between the two which is definitely not
what we want we want this metal coat to
be
visible only on the scratched edges
right so
let's delete the float for now
and
[Music]
let's grab
this scratched edges
setup that we made no need to do it
again
i'll control
oh this is
yeah i'll control drag it
because it'll probably need to be its
own deal
and that'll go into the amount
sweet and then i'm just going to update
this on the parts that uh that have this
material so
bam bam
bam
bam
i think that's everything let's refresh
octane
hard to tell if it's
doing
what we need it to do
so let's go ahead and right click the
gradient and solo it
all right it's not
soloing for some reason
try and sell the noise
that's not soloing for some reason okay
let's refresh octane maybe
interesting
this should be
oh i know why i know why sometimes with
octane you have to switch back to your
viewport in order for it to update
that's just some jankiness you know what
i mean
so we need to flip the order of this
it's opposite so
let's pipe the metal into material two
and our
paint material into material one
hey there we go that's a nice
rusted
corroded looking
metal right there i'm a fan of that
that looks great
that's what i'm talking about yeah
sweet all right all right
let me go ahead and go through here and
set all of these black and white uh
surface imperfections to float notice
the vram used is
1.85 let's see what it's at when i go
through
and change these
i guess there's only two
1.85 and that goes down to
1.68 that's what's up saving vram making
our stuff look good
um
let's go ahead and
choke the
this noise just a little bit
so the best way to do that would
probably be
so this is getting really detailed right
now but like
basically
our
okay what's the best way to explain this
we have this metal we're chipping away
to reveal the metal right and it's the
same
noise setup that chips away to reveal
our
our base coat paint
but i actually want to see a little bit
of that base coat paint on the outer
layer of this chipped away
paint
so i need to kind of choke i need to
choke the uh
the mask a bit so
let me see if this works i'm just gonna
bring this in gradient in all the way in
let's take it all the way in until it's
invisible
all right you see what you see i'm
talking about you can see how we have
that base coat
in there and we open it up just a bit
what does this do
okay that gives us more
let's take this down
like there
and then crunch that
so you see how it kind of like
we don't have all the shine up here now
if i were to open this up a little bit
we'd start to reveal more
of that shiny
corrosive look which i kind of like it
like that
so i might just bring it in just a touch
that feels pretty good to me
awesome
now the last thing i do this is like
the this is all just like
texturing surface imperfection
uh
like defaults i always do this i always
do the scratches i always chip away to
reveal the the edges like that but now
it's time for
the dirt version okay so we kind of have
two
we're building up a series here we have
um
our octane glossy which we can call this
base paint
we have this mixed material
we can call this um
scratched paint
and then we're going to make one more
a mixed material on top of the mixed
material and that's going to be our
um
our dirty
scratched paint right so hopefully this
all makes sense mark
d with the super chat
love watching these challenges even
though i hadn't used the 3d software
since i was uh at uni 15 years ago
shout outs to you man uh i'm glad you're
here thanks for watching i'm i'm glad
you dig the challenges
and uh 15 years ago at uni that was a
while that was a while we're probably
similar
similar age are we a similar age yeah
just about
pretty pretty close you might be a
little older than myself but hey i'm
glad that you're here thank you for the
super chat thanks for the support much
love much appreciated
all right mark d
we're going to dirty this up here all
right
oh visual you say delete the normal
slash phong tags on your geo it'll help
with artifacting
cool yeah i'll do that um next time i
see it
shout outs
okay
um
let's just make a quick
i get sidetracked y'all i get
sidetracked
i'm gonna make a quick like
um
blank screen
material
just cuz okay so we have a screen
and
i don't know why it has that material on
it
unless
it doesn't and there's some z fighting
going on
i'm so confused
why is that not showing up
what
sometimes
things are just janky
what
come on now
there we go
yeah i should probably do like
material um
selections and whatnot for this but
whatever
okay
let's do this really quick um
octane glossy material i'm just going to
call this screen
let's drop it on
and
let's go ahead
and
make it like a
dark
gray green
yeah that's
darn close that's darn close
i love it
that's nasty
okay and then i think it's as simple as
uh
i'm gonna try i'm gonna try a couple
things i'm gonna try this this may not
work
um
sotomonte sonamonte with the super chat
yeah where's the sound coming from
nobody knows
nobody knows
i might have instruments duct taped to
my feet
nobody knows
shout outs i'll play a little song for
you super chats get a little a little
little song a little song and dance
um
let's see
all right
i love that color so much that's awesome
okay let's go up in here let's give it
some surface imperfections
wayne
langley my goodness with the super chat
wayne
i really appreciate you
it's hard to play this beat while i give
the super chat out but
thoughts on substance painter hopefully
this is not too loud um
that would save me tons of vram yes it
would
yes it would i'm gonna learn substance
painter
and uh
it's hard to think and play this song at
the same time
but yes i'm gonna learn substance
painter
it's something i've wanted to learn for
a very long time it is very high on my
list
it is probably the highest on my list
right now you're right it will save me a
ton of time
absolutely
okay
focus let's get focused i'm trying to
drop a
surface imperfection here from my
surface imperfection pack
um
let's do
1k
i don't know why i'd be touching the
screen like this but
let's pipe that into roughness
ah that looks great already
and we got save the polar bears let's
see if i can do
what is my favorite part of making a
project
um i really enjoy
it's so hard
i really enjoy the
texturing aspect i love like finalizing
it once i get to a point where it looks
nice and i'm just doing my tweaks and
stuff that is
the best
um
other than that like
yeah
materials i'm at the point where like
this is really fun for me because it
comes to life
and then once it's once it's come to
life and i render it out waking up
in the morning to a finished render is
some of the most satisfying exciting
things to do so
that's definitely
a big part of it finishing it you know
like coming to the finish line on on a
big project is a blast
so
yeah absolutely absolutely
will i get feverikin for the winter
video again
i'm always collaborating with my buddy
feverkin he is amazing however i am
trying to
mix it up i want to try and mix it up so
um i
am not ready to announce anything yet
but
i am speaking with a musician
and i can't wait
uh
for y'all to hear
what this musician will be working on
they hadn't started yet
but we're getting the references you
know we're sending references back and
forth right now
um so it's a it's a good time it's a
very very good time i'm very excited
all right um
materials projection
node yes projection box projection
transform
let's go ahead and scale that thing down
0.1
great
and let's give it an octane gradient
take this black up to
nothing like that we actually want to
keep it very subtle
i'd say something in that range
and let's try a thing with the bump i
want to try this really quick so let's
go uh
octane
noise
and let's take the contrast to 100
and let's take the projection
to
xyz to uvw
the transform
will take down
to 0.1
and then i'm going to
um
i am going to
unlink these and stretch this
in a certain direction
the right direction
and then i'm just gonna shrink it down
i'll lock it again
yep just like that
and let's throw a multiply on it and a
float
to chill it out it's just too it's
it's partying too hard right now
point one
still partying too hard .01
still going too hard.001
let's take the contrast down
it's probably not what i'm going for
actually i think this like
scanline effect is actually
on the monitor like it's in the monitor
on the back of the monitor it's not on
the top of the monitor
so i'm gonna forget about that
[Music]
and i might take this
a little bit more intense i don't know
yikes
let me try another one
steve yo steve begin
what's up dude shout outs to you
sensei steve in the house um i am using
my sony a7r ii with a g master
24 to 70 2.8 aperture lens
yep
soto's got it
it's also in the description too
um
for those of you who are here who are
curious
so we can kind of chill out
the imperfections there
by bringing that white closer to black
hey that feels pretty good to me
um
cool
all right let's let's do our final thing
here and let's
let's add this dirt okay
so let's go ahead and duplicate the
scratched paint or rather no no we're
not gonna do that we're going to make a
new mix material i'll go in here and
we're going to call this uh
dirty
dirty uh dirty paint
that's what we're gonna call it and
we're gonna take this whole scratch
paint set up
bring this up
this will be piped into material
one
and we're gonna have
just simply a color
i'm gonna go with an rgb spectrum
that'll be
material two
oh i need a whole material don't i well
i can do this hold on now hold on hold
on now
let me think about this
can i do this from here
i think i can do it from the scratched
paint
just simply from here
because
it's really in
it's really up in here
is what's doing it um
[Music]
okay let me think about this
i'm gonna keep it separate just to keep
things clean
so i'll make a new material
just a simple diffuse material i'm going
to just call this dirt
and
i'm going to
frame all yep and just change this
i'll give it an rgb spectrum and i'm
gonna
color it something
[Music]
something like i don't know something
like this something dirty
we can always come back to that
that's
that's it very simple very very simple
and then let's make a new mix material
and this new mix material
is going to utilize
our scratched paint
in material
2 and our dirt
material in material one
and let's go ahead and apply this
first i'll name it we're gonna call this
dirty
paint
and if you notice here
in the top right
it's not updating it still it looks like
a white matte situation
if you click on your material that isn't
updating and you kind of double click it
in this preview window it'll update in
here again just another
another glitch there but
it is what it is right
so let's take dirty paint let's apply
that to all of the parts that need it
okay
and remember we have to kind of switch
back to the view mode there
mm-hmm
and we'll get it here too
wonderful all right um that actually
looks kind of cool too
and again we can just change the color
of our
material
to get whatever color base base color we
want so that's actually pretty sweet
okay
um
let's replace the amount so this is
where we're mixing between
uh our scratched paint and our dirt
right back and forth between the two
we don't want to do it like that we want
to actually use a smudge
or i have footprints i have dust i have
dust wipes
you know there's so many different
options
um
we can just try pulling this option and
see what it does
for the amount
let's go ahead and work the projection
okay
box projection
transform
we can scale that down
0.1
and we can adjust the gamma to 1 to get
a little bit more out of that dirt
as you can see
it's kind of maybe not the best dirt
we could definitely go for more of like
a wiped kind of situation
and it's very subtle right now
but that's okay
our reference is
something like this
right
you see it's kind of built up a bit more
on the
like near the buttons in the cracks and
stuff so we're gonna we're gonna do a
whole thing to get that doing a thing we
can also
have this be
on the top of everything too like a dust
layer has settled on the top of all of
it which we'll definitely want to do
because in my scene it's a supercar it's
like a rocket car
um that they bring out to the desert and
they drive very fast in the desert so
there's always dirt being kicked up
and it'll probably settle
from the top down so i can show you guys
how to do that but we got only js
with a super chat
what's up dude um shout outs to you
how's the new r25 layout you know to be
honest i'm getting used to it
i'm getting used to it they changed the
a lot of stuff they kind of changed um
where certain things are what certain
things are called so that's a little
annoying but
um
[Music]
and they changed all their icons too
i'm getting used to it
yeah i'm getting used to it it's not the
worst thing ever it's not the best thing
ever either but it is what it is
all right
so we kind of have like a top layer of
dirt here i'm kind of just going through
my different
dirt surface imperfections that one's
really
really nice
that one has like a bunch of wipes and
stuff we can maybe scale that up 0.2
that's not bad
that's not bad at all as like a top coat
kind of situation
um
now if we want it in the cracks if we
want dirt collected in the corners of
everything we're going to use a dirt
node again
right and that's exactly what it's for
that's why it's called a dirt node so
i'm going to pull out a dirt node
and let's
take this
take the radius to 0.1
let's solo it to see what the heck is
going on
and it's not soloing for us okay
fantastic
strength 10
so it's doing what
um
there we go you see it's in the corners
there but it's just
inverted we need to invert it
is that doing what we want it to do
it's not it's not okay
so let's
um
i guess this means we have to flip our
materials around
yep there we go
you see that how it's like
up in the corners
or the cracks rather where everything
meets
that's exactly what we want we can scale
it up
okay so we can go like .7 on it or
something
or even just one centimeter so
it's pretty darn dusty
and we want to break it up
it's not just a full-on thing it's like
there's fingerprints there's smudges in
it taking away it's removing it so we
want to remove some of this with a
surface imperfection
so
i think what we'll do here
is we have this one right so we we set
this up
and i think this just needs to be
inverted
you know we could use smudges too
um
oh we got a super chat let me think of a
new beat um
you know it doesn't really work that way
we're just doing it
hunter for hire
hey clint so i submitted an older
version of my work a week ago big
mistake
big mistake big mistake dude big mistake
i've improved it this week is it
possible to avoid it and submit again
dude
ah no
we said so many times this is your final
version of your final version i said if
you submit a work in progress this this
is your work in progress submitted you
can only submit once you can only submit
one time that's brutal man i'm sorry but
like
you know that's just the way it is um
yeah uh
yeah there's there's so many check boxes
and and warnings saying don't don't do
that because
there's no reason to submit until you're
done with your work until the end so
take all the time you can
i'm sorry uh hunter that that happened
to you
that's a bummer for sure um but those
warnings were there we put them there
for a reason man
i can't make an exception for everybody
otherwise it'd be hell for me in the end
here trying to get everyone's renders
together and have to update the new one
update the new one find the new file
find the new file there's just no way
there'd be no way to put out the montage
in a
reasonable amount of time so f's in the
chat
shout outs to you man
now i will say that like
there's certainly no harm in in
improving your render if you want to
keep improving it for your real um and
for your side of things but
once it's submitted once it's submitted
once man
um sorry to hear that dude
but that's why we got those warnings
there
all right
let's see
um
i think i have some other
i got like footsteps i know i got
footsteps um we got grunge
lots of different grunge i don't know if
grunge is the way to go on this it could
be
let's set this to float
one
it looks kind of cool so i want to pair
these together i only want this to
be um in the areas that this dirt node
is allowing okay
so
how are we gonna do this
we it's usually it's usually like a a
series of
trial and error i'll try it with a um
with a multiply node first
and i could be wrong it could be an add
node
all right so that's getting both
that's adding both the dirt node and
this
surface imperfection we don't want that
i'm gonna flip it just in case
yeah it's getting both
i think it's an ad
so let's try the add node
we want to add
this to this
and that totally did it that totally did
it yep
amazing
all right so i'm just going to switch
this out until it looks like how we want
it to look
where all the dirt is in the corners and
that's actually not bad
we could also do
um i can use my uh
instead of like a grunge or
like a dirt wipe we can actually try
a dust
oh sorry a fiber a fiber so we can do
more of like a
is that even working
it's really hard to tell if it's working
or not
yeah that might be a little too too
subtle huh
fiber
yeah that's way too subtle
we can just keep going with the dust
and see
what works here
you know that's not bad
i think we can crunch it
so i'll do a
octane gradient
and crunch it
the other way
there you go
you can really see
that dirtiness there
um
this could also be done with a noise
node too
but i'm gonna keep
[Music]
working
this surface imperfection
[Music]
until it looks right um
it's annoying that i can't solo this
thing
but that's okay
um let's try this dust
this dust
and i just had an idea i'm just gonna
add something real quick i think um this
first one works the best
it looks really nice it's pretty
apparent
so we can always
dial this back and make it more subtle
you know what i mean so
that's all good right um but we have no
dirt on top we want to have some dirt
kind of on top and all throughout so
we're going to mix all this stuff
together this is one chunk of the dirt
right
so let's go ahead and know that this is
working
okay i'm gonna remove it
and then i'm just gonna go ahead and
like
let's let's try doing fiber
let's try putting a fiber
uh
imperfection in here let's invert it
set it to 1
on the gamma that's going to open it up
a little bit and then i'm going to get a
little octane gradient in here
and go to crunch town
yeah you can there you see it's doing
something but we need the proper
projection and transform so i'm gonna
just pipe this projection in
awesome looks horrible and then we'll do
a transform and scale it down we'll go
0.1 on it
so those are like nice little specks of
dust and stuff
0.1 we go 0.05
even
and like those little bits
instead of being like
bits of dirt well you know that's
actually it's not the worst um
let me take this dirt and brighten it up
a touch
there we go
it's not bad
very subtle again we'll set that to
float because it's a black and white
material
so it's kind of like a little overall
dirt and then we can do we can mix this
together probably we'll do a mix
material
or a mix node rather
and that's not the amount i just want to
do a 50 50
float
0.5 yep and then i'ma bust out
essentially just duplicate this setup
ctrl drag
pipe that in
pipe this into the projection
and drop a new
one here so maybe i'll do this wipe
it's super subtle but it's there you
know
we can scale it up
and finally
we could do a layer of dust just on the
top
so
um
the way i'll do that right so we so we
know once again we have our corner dirt
and we have our overall dirt
now we're gonna need top dirt
okay so
let's set up our top dirt and then we'll
we'll combine all these together right
so let's
pull that out
get it
going yeah all right we're gonna do a
fall off node i think a falloff node bam
that's what it is and a falloff node is
basically
um
gonna let us choose a direction so we
can change this mode to normal versus
vector 90 degrees and already by default
it's just doing the stuff on top right
so the dust falls and lands on top
we can set the minimum value
and the
the max min and max values right so we
can chill out that dust
um fall off skew factor
yeah so that just kind of like rolls it
off
a little nicer which i like
and instead of it being a full-on blast
like this
let's have it be
let's actually pull
from this material here
i'm gonna remove it from this mix
texture
and i'm just going to include this
like this will be its own situation
right here
let's get rid of that
and that right so we just have like our
speckled dust that's our overall dust
and then the wiped dust will be our top
dust okay
so
we want to combine these two together i
think it's with an ad we're going to add
these together
and yep 100
you don't see the wipes on the side but
you see the wipes on the top
it's exactly what we want
we can change our gamma so it's more
intense
we can scale it up so the wipes are more
you know from someone's hand they'd be a
little bit larger so maybe 0.3
0.2
something like that
feels good to me
so now we're going to combine all three
of these okay
so we have our
top dust
we have our overall dust
and we have our
crack dust
[Laughter]
so let's let's let's uh let's combine
all this stuff here and i think it's
gonna be through a multiply node i think
so let's try
and start with our top dust and our
crack dust i love saying that um
multiply node
boom and boom
and it's exactly what we want heck yeah
now we just need to multiply
those with this
okay so for organization's sake i'll
bring that up
this comes down
right we have this stuff going in let's
flip these two just for again
organizational
sake i think you can right click and hit
uh
auto arrange selected
for some reason it's not doing anything
it's right here auto arrange
kind of works there um
right and then finally yeah right so we
we want to combine these this multiply
with another multiply
for our our overall
dust
goes into the amount
this
boom comes in there
and i think we some we should have some
overall dust
on this thing
um
this is our overall dust huh
hard to tell right now
maybe we can go
yep we have it
it's very subtle
there it is there it is there it is
brian mahoney yo
love the image of someone walking on it
uh walking in on clint talking about
crack dust to his computer with bells
tapped taped to his feet
yep
yep
we gotta add that crack dust dude just
put the crack dust in there it's perfect
but i'm not wrong i'm not wrong am i
okay
we kind of have
an old dusty monitor that we just
textured
it's probably a little um
a little heavy on the dust
but
we can smooth that out
a little bit later
i think that'll be fine but brian hey
shout outs for the super chat it's
hilarious dude i'm glad you're having a
good time
i hope everyone else is having a good
time
we got 587 people up here in the chat
it's like it's always a good time
um
sweet and also shout outs to all you who
who purchased
my surface imperfections just now i see
ya
we got i think 15 people who just bought
the for the surface imperfections but i
also have my concrete materials and my
hdris
the hdris are okay you know they work
they're gonna work right they're gonna
work they're only four bucks right for a
whole pack of
12 or 15 or something like that um but
it really comes down to the concrete
materials they're endless concrete
materials they just go on forever you
never like tiling isn't an issue because
these things are massive
um i'm talking a hundred
thousand pixels long
uh they're absurd they're absurd i have
versions 1k 2k 4k of course
but it gets to 100k
and then uh of course i'm using these
surface imperfections here on the stream
i got those up half off as well just for
this stream only so shout outs to all
you guys who have been using them i hope
they work out for you
i love using them myself
good times
very very good times
okay
let's see
i think the dirt is a little intense
so
one way we can chill
it all out i think is by putting a
gradient right here at the end
so let's go octane gradient
and let's take the black and make it
white and see what happens
it gets rid of it okay so if we make the
white
a gray
then we get a little bit of dirt we make
it a little bit wider we get just a
touch of dirt and i think that's all you
really need it's just the
just the touch it's very subtle we don't
want to go so intense with this
um and the scratches i want to chill out
so let's go scratched paint
let's see what we're doing here
on our scratched paint
let's go to the actual paint layer
and
find out what is doing our overall paint
i believe that's going to be
this one here
i'm just going to scale
this up
0.3
and i'm going to chill it out just a
little bit so i might go like 4 on the
gamma
just to chill it out a touch it's a
little much
cool
that feels darn good to me
going back to our reference
we're kind of doing our dirt like this
and
we have our base coat like this
that's feeling good to me is feeling
very good to me
whether or not we go with this color i
don't know
but let's um let's finish
texturing
this tv while we're at it right so we
have these knobs
these are kind of like like a rubber
slash plastic
so i think what we'll do here is
just make
a rubber slash plastic
so i'll make a glossy material
i'm going to apply this glossy material
to these knobs
boom
let's go up in here
[Music]
node editor view frame all if you're
having trouble finding it okay
and
yeah we want it to be black
but it's not going to be totally black
right that obviously doesn't look right
roughness will need to take up
uh with a float you know but you know
you just do it in here too
roughness we can set to
point
three i don't know
0.6
and i have reference right you know i
got reference on this stuff
right here
it's kind of like a hard plastic
and this is a good material to have so
i'm let's build this out let's build
this hard plastic out
um it's not as shiny as this so i would
say 0.8 maybe on the roughness
0.9
and it has some texture to it right so
that bump let's grab the bump that we
already set up let's save ourselves some
time yeah
so i'll go to the base paint
go to our bump
i'm going to just copy this over
ctrl c
you all know how to copy paste at this
point
come on
ctrl v
get that in the bump and you can see
there's a little bit of texture now on
these guys
and viewed from this distance
it's a bit difficult to tell
so maybe we we beef it
0.02
so we're adjusting the intensity 0.03
they don't look
the best
it's really hard to tell to be honest
like from all the way back here
and i still feel like they're too shiny
so let's take that float to 1
and we can even take our index to like
1.5 or no no it'd be the other way 1.2
oh no 1.3 is good one point three one
point three one point three
that's cool school school
well you can take this value to 0.015
now i know the bump is a little large
for what this is what this is if we were
viewing it at this distance
i would probably take it to like
something
even smaller
even smaller 0.001
somewhere in here i would take it to
something like this but we're not
viewing it from this distance i have a
video on this actually
um
it's the one
with like
where i model the fountain pen the knife
my water bottle and my aeropex
headphones
um
and i talk about when when when actually
texturing
the fountain pen it's a very similar
texture as to what i'm doing right now
it has like some some texture to it
right it's not just a flat
plastic there's actually some like some
texture to it and depending on what
angle you're viewing it from
that texture will change
so just because this is photo accurate i
zoom out out here i can't even tell
right so i'm gonna i want to make it a
little bit larger so i'll take it to
like .01 or something and then you can
actually kind of tell from this distance
what that plastic kind of looks like
so hopefully that gives you guys an idea
um mtu mto creations we got a super chat
up in the house mto creations yo my dude
you're a legend for me your channel
helped me work through a lot of stuff
with four f's stuff
i ran into on a project i had for a
client thank you dude that's what's up
i'm glad i could help out i'm glad you
got through the project with the client
i hope you learned a lot
i'm sure you did um
so shout outs to you man thank you for
the support thank you for the help um it
really means a lot
it allows me like all your guys to
support whether you're a patron whether
you're buying my my textures today
on the stream
whether you're super chatting
um
any of that stuff like
is extremely extremely helpful it allows
me to do this full time
and pay for help you know like we got
sotomonte up in the chat shout outs to
sotomonte he's helping me stream produce
i'm able to pay him just a little bit
you know so all that stuff really helps
and makes life a little bit easier for
all of us so i really appreciate you
everyone here super chatting uh mto
shout out to ya thank you so much
thanks for hanging out with us man good
times
alright so this black is a little too
black
i want to just gray it up a touch
that feels a little bit better to me
that's yeah that feels a little bit
better to me
um and then let's add some dirt to it
why not
let's go ahead and make a mix node
we can mix node
um
with an rgb spectrum
two of them
one of them will be our base black color
all right
so i'm going to ah it's doing it again
good goodness
it's just it's just dark gray
okay and then the other one will be a
dirt color which i actually do want to
reference the dirt color i want to keep
my dirt
color consistent so
let me pull dirty paint
and i'm going to go to
the rgb spectrum
where are you
where are you
here it is
boom i'll pull that keep my dirt color
consistent
bam
wham okay
and then the amount will be
a
okay we'll do it with
a surface imperfection
not noise
we probably could do it with
a surface imperfection
or with noise but
for the bigger stuff
like when it's across a giant dashboard
i want it to look better than just noise
okay so
projection
we'll go box
transform node yes please
we know we need to scale it down
0.1
it's so subtle
probably not going to see it on these
knobs
i'll set the game at a 1
and the transform to maybe 0.05
and maybe we pull another
dust
the wipes
super subtle
very very subtle
we could just
you know have uh this
this dirt be on top with a fall off node
but i think for what we're doing right
now it's gonna be
okay i would rather just pull all the
stuff that we have from
the dirty paint material that we'd set
up but i think we're good
ooh you know what too
we can make two of these right so we can
choose based off of what we want we can
have a
we can have a black plastic
and we could have like a
a matte kind of gray plastic
which i saw in another reference
i don't have it here
excuse me whoa
it's kind of like this blurry one in the
background here
this blurry matte color in the back
or what we could do is actually start
working some of this orange
and make some orange knobs but i feel
like oh it's kind of like this it's kind
of like this over here
well let's give it a shot let's let's
see
what it can look like so for these four
mini ones
let's see if we can't change the color
of that
right so black plastic i'll just call
this white
plastic
come up in here
and change this black to
basically just like a gray
if i drop it on there will it update yes
it does
see like that looks like um
something i've seen before
those knobs
and i might even like it better
than the black
but i don't know maybe the black kind of
works there
um
we could do an orange ring around this
so maybe the small
small knob
as
a little edit in here we can go boom
boom
and we make a orange plastic
right we can pull
um
let's see
um
hmm
i wish this color picker would work
very frustrating i guess we could cheat
it right we can go here
pull this one
i'm grabbing this orange from off screen
on my
reference and then
we can find the code for it
254 155
254
155 this is such a backwards way of
doing this i bet
god come on
254
155
54.
that's the orange we want
cool so then we just update that
ul for loop selection
drag and drop it
and it's oh
try that again does that not work now
can you not
weird why is it doing the whole thing
so i set selection
what the heck
um
oh
wait is that why
yeah okay okay
uh we got mto creations what is up once
again thank you for the super sticker
keep it up boy i am keeping it on up
i love doing this it's very fun
i appreciate you
very very much
very much
let's see if i can do okay so this is um
for those of you who enjoy music
um
we got time signatures okay so this is
your classic
four four one two three four one two
and then one two three one two three one
two three one two three and you put them
together and you get
it's a good little jam
feels nice
but you can do five over four so one two
three four five one two three four five
one two three four five one two three
four and it's like
and you can combine all three together
see if i do this
um
it says
nope not right now i'll chill on that
for a second but
mto creations shout outs cryptopia thank
you hours on one shader drag and drop
next time love it um
hours on one shader
drag and drop next time
i'm trying to figure out
i'm trying to figure out what that means
i spent hours on one shader i got that
drag and drop next time as in just like
anyway i
appreciate the super chat
thank you so much thank you so much yeah
paulie rhythms
y'all know i'm i'm a huge fan i'm a
drummer so
you know it's that's all about the
polyrhythms
all about it you try and get like the
offbeat like
um
and it's hard to tell out of context
with like without a snare drum
seven over five seven over five would be
like
uh
seven is uh
over five
god dang i could use negative seven over
four
or seven or five or uh four over
five over four
and offbeat
i love drums i love drums very very much
yeah i'm working on seven
uh sorry i'm working on three four and
five at the same time which is let me
see if i can do this let me see if i can
do this
uh
it's like
um
[Music]
[Music]
god dang
yeah that'll opt out off the chill on
that for a little bit okay
back to it
appreciate y'all getting through my uh
my silliness
all right
um let's try and
what do we want to do from here y'all
what do we want to do from here
we kind of got our setup here i'm
wondering what i can do for
should this be the black plastic i don't
know
what would this be what color would this
handle be i feel like it would be
plastic
but i don't know if it would be
black
plastic
um
it looks okay
that looks okay
i know this in here
would probably be
i don't think it would be dirty
but i also don't know if you can tell
yeah so that's probably fine
so you think knobs need to be a little
darker
like that
potentially
potentially
uh i know this needs to be
black as well
and that needs to be okay so we gotta do
a little thing here we got this
now let's set our scene let's set our
clipping to tiny
so shift what is it ctrl d ctrl d
view clipping will set to small all
right
so
that is going to be
black along with that
and that will be
black
plastic
wow
that's not good
um
and then this
should just be a void
actually so let me just update that
that'll be fine and then basically
everything in here
it's gonna be chromed out
so we can drag our iron from grayscale
gorilla
up in there
and hopefully when we subdivide it it's
gonna look
decent um
let's grab these two
and add that
boom
it still doesn't look chrome to me uh
okay that's why
we don't have a selection for it so i'm
gonna
make sure we do boom boom boom
come on now
make a selection
add this to the selection
there we go should be right
eh good enough
good enough
people aren't really going to see that
to be so
hidden
and another thing i want to add actually
here is uh
some like a little like indicator of
where the knob actually is
so
now we're getting into modeling but
whatever i'm just adding this really
quick
just a simple cylinder
the heck how many cylinders do we
well it's for everything that's right
yeah
cool and then i'm just gonna
control drag this over
awesome the feet can just be metal
which i should probably just do once
legs
yep
and
this monitor
like the outside of this monitor will
probably just be um
black as well
and i think what i'll do for that
is take the dirty the black or as i take
the dirty paint
control
drag it to duplicate
and i'm gonna change the paint color
see if this works
i might have to duplicate just the
paint itself
uh is why this is kind of annoying
see
ah changes everything
it's no good
raj official
oh
snap
yes yes
raj official
thank you for the super chat
much appreciated man
it's awesome
it's very generous of you
which i very very much appreciate it's
so hard to talk and play beats at the
same time um
i'm glad you enjoy the content i hope
you're learning something it's always a
good time man so thank you thank you
thank you so so much
heck yeah
oh i've been working on this one i've
been working on uh
oh my god it's me so hard with my feet
i really gotta focus on that you know
really gotta kill this no i could talk
at the same time absolutely not
oh boy
all right
um
let's just get this last piece colored
and move on yeah
this bit
we just want black plastic
that didn't do what i wanted it to do
yeah i just want this to be
uh let's make a
yes indeed and then we'll drag
material
pop it on there
yeah that's what that's what i want but
it's annoying that the bevel
like still keeps it as that turquoise
so i don't know it could be
removed but then it removes the bevel
from there which doesn't look good
so i don't know i i will leave it for
now and dig into the details of that
at another time perhaps
uh one thing i'm gonna do is like add a
bunch of stickers to this probably later
um
but i don't think we really need to
touch on that right now
i'm not really happy with this black
plastic here on the side i feel like it
would be something else i'll try white
plastic and see if that does anything
if i like that any better
maybe that feels a little bit better
i can always change it later that's the
best part you just change it later
maybe we make it orange
it's probably not the way to go it's
definitely not the way to go
yeah
you could do a brown like a nasty brown
that could potentially work but
all good
all right let's go back to our scene
let's let's drop this into our scene
actually let's take this monitor
and drop it into our actual scene here
see let's paste it in
and i'll use the uh transfer tool
to have it basically sit right up in
here
bam and let's go ahead and get rid of
this monitor
and replace it
sweet
it looks awesome and again to keep my
viewport as like chill as possible i'm
just going to hit enqueue to hide all
the materials
let's see what it looks like
and
we got
another super chat from nicola
tesla
what's up
how you doing
many thanks for the super chat hey bro
big fan will you do portfolio review um
i've never done portfolio review on my
patreon i have art review where i'll
like go over people's art and stuff um
limited to five people per month at the
top tier um
i mostly just keep the art review and
stuff to that and um
and uh
you know on uh sorry on uh the
weekly challenge we do weekly challenges
but it's not like a super in-depth
review i will say this like if you're on
discord maybe just send it to me i'll
take a look and see
let's see what's going on but thank you
for the super chat much appreciate it
all right
okay so that's very dark
but that's okay
because we can brighten things up a
little bit
let's um
take the vignette off
let's take the exposure i think what's
keeping this so dark is
certainly the lighting
i think it's the sun power perhaps
we can take exposure to three
we can also take our colors and
brighten up our colors too
right
aaron smith i love what
uh where your head's at make sure to
save everybody make sure to save
um
so yeah you notice that this looks a lot
different than it did
in our our little test setup that we had
right
i'm actually going to save this as a
monitor
that looks really nice
but yeah it just looks a lot darker we
can't really see any of the details and
whatnot so
that probably has a little bit to do
with lighting and probably has a little
bit to do with the textures
um
[Music]
so i'm not too worried about it i think
we can continue though let's do a
what do i want to do next
hmm
yeah you know what guys let's do a work
in progress review
we're
probably an hour and a half into the
stream or something like that
let's take a look at y'all's work in
progress
and see how you guys are doing
so let me pull up the old
discord here
and navigate
the whip
or stream
sweet
so last we
left off
was i think at mdk's
render
so we can go from there
oh that's his most recent
there we go i think this is where we
left off
yeah i believe this is where we left off
all right so let's just go down and see
what we got jason
got a little metro 2049 thing i like
your exterior man very
cool you got some cool animation here on
the bench
moving your
all your different props around i like
that a lot
i dig it i dig it
gordon
ah the beds man the beds on the train is
such a vibe
ooh
let's see what did i start a little too
let's see i think
is this new i'm trying to make sure i'm
in the right spot here
okay look
all right here let's do it like this
let me check
bam right here
sweet all right this is it then
boom all right
edge snap okay edge is freaking
crushing it
oh this looks great
this looks awesome
animated very well you got like
dang yeah all the little details this
the
fire hydrant is moving properly the
cables are moving
the like gps thing is moving here
the camera shake is really nice
ah these cables are are great man this
is solid this is such a good one i can't
wait to see how this turns out edge
oh it's awesome shadow dwarf too
oh nice little uh
like star wars chess
oh
getting a little aggro there
sweet sweet i like all your detail on
the wall here super cool
characters are fun as well
nice larry what do you got
sweet been modeling your stuff got a
character got some crazy stuff outside
i'm excited to see how that turns out
whoa okay so we got a background
oh cool
it's moritz i think that's your name
very interesting oh i didn't even see
the character there
wow
some crazy time warping situation there
sweet got a sci-fi scene all right nice
very
nice cool let's see
oh it's like mass effect style very
awesome
wow this is cool
i love your atmosphere the clouds there
are really nice oh this is awesome okay
so it's an avatar
scene this is sweet
yeah this is really cool i can't wait to
see that in motion
oh okay sakura you got a little
minecraft scene here
yes i love it it's very cute very fun
i love this art style i'm excited to see
more art styles like this
you know a lot of us are doing photo
reel which is totally fine
this is cool i like i like this a lot
very adventurous i want to play a video
game like this
hey i recognize that camera
what is that um
model haven modelhaven.com
oh snap yes
i love the idea
someone coming from the background into
the foreground that's really cool
i like that a lot
who is this c2 i'm not even gonna try
but c29 i like it that's it's fun
what do we got here tk
oh very interesting okay
very interesting world
very curious what's going on there
andy wren
i recognize that name
oh my god
terrifying
absolutely terrifying
oh the full window there is is pretty
interesting that's cool
exo me
this this person's just having a day
they got their legs kicking
there's nothing happier than just
kicking your swinging your legs you know
oh wow
this is so unique yes i love the idea
yeah very very unique
i love it matthew merrick
super cool humicular is proud another
name i recognize
hmm
that's cool
very fun
very playful
keep it up good stuff amicular
i think i remember this from last time
yeah you made some good progress
cool robot nice colors on the robot
there
this is great
that's very very fun
kazaar what's going on here wow
it's a burnt up place
dang
that's rough
rough environment to be in i wouldn't
want to be here
that is for sure
now this is looking very nice alt f4
this is beautiful your lighting is solid
your characters the color contrast
between the shorts and the shirt is
solid
and the details you're adding here are
really nice
a bunch of personal pictures
calendar
some books jurassic park great book
solid book
this is great
this looks super nice i can't wait to
see this in his final form alt f4 that's
amazing suggestions give you suggestions
um
hard to say without it being in motion
but
i hope that your string of pictures are
moving i hope that your cloth is moving
with
with like the actual
thing here
her position looks a little rough to
like hold
if i was her i would be like wanting to
sit up against something so i don't have
to like use my abs you know all day
and is that what her boyfriend driving
husband
brother
who are these people
i assume they're friends going to some
sort of event out in the desert
somewhere
they're going camping perhaps
i i dig it i think it's great
it's really fun
all right i'm just going to keep going
because we probably have a lot here
marcus seam
oh this is very interesting
very interesting
i like the idea it's very very fun i
think the only thing you have to work on
is your animation just work on smoothing
out that animation
use reference film yourself doing this
just match your reference
the bird probably be flying a little
faster too but i love that idea super
cool
yes
yes
oh this is great
very very fun trying to figure out how
to convert it back to 24 fps
well this is definitely a vibe you're
going for so like if it's the 12 fps
situation
i think that's fine
as long as it's
24 frames per second in its final output
you know
um which it looks like it already is so
i think you're looking good i think to
worry about too much
veli
i love this
very nice
i love it it's like claymation
very unique
i love it i love the uniqueness i love
it when these renders just go beyond the
photo reel kind of vibe you know
nice and cozy inside it's very cold
outside good surface imperfections
that's awesome
very cool
oh wow okay i remember this render
so you're actually drawing something
here in the glass that's very nice
i like that a lot
that's great
pan pipan i love it
more star wars chess okay
nice very nice maybe work on your motion
blur you'll probably have that when you
when you render it oh jack the heck yes
sweet okay so you redid the background
to keep it just in focus the whole time
yeah that's smart smart
yeah i think the only thing you have to
work on here jack is the animation it's
just like a little stiff
it's very very tough
very very tough
um
use reference when you can but otherwise
this is looking amazing i really dig the
idea and i dig your scene here
just keep tweaking that animation very
good stuff good lighting too
interesting
interesting
zap
a world war ii scene
definitely watch your motion blur there
sweet all right
earthworm jim
someone said i look like earthworm jim a
while ago and like that made no sense to
me
this is great
this is gonna be good
wow great detail great design great
animation
great character
yes yes yes yes
that's so much fun
i love it i can't wait for that one cd
legacy
that's gonna be sick
oh we got ronan posting on behalf of
game factory
okay so this is game factories
dang this is crazy
emergency flood situation
wow
that's terrifying i would not want to be
this person
that's so cool
with the water sim and everything
i like your uh architectural design here
that looks really nice
you know i bet i i don't think you need
the water on the glass though i think it
takes away
and it would technically be out of focus
and blurry
so i'd consider consider maybe
blurring that out a whole bunch or
removing it because i don't think it
needs it
that's a really cool one
wait this is also the game factory whoa
whoa
these are two very different renders
i love the infinite journeys closed too
wow
that's nuts
super cool
also that was a previous and this is
what you changed it to wow this is this
is great
yeah this is this has a lot more going
on for it like i can tell
what's going on and it's a bit more
clear
you take in a little bit more of the
environment as well i dig that game
factory super cool
casual night
okay this is render
looks like some last of us
oh this is where this is where it was
and this is where it is
your lighting has definitely improved i
love it
yeah
wow that's a cool background
sated
is that your name
i dig that that's cool
yeah heck yeah
i love it
oh
yes
this is this is a great idea okay here
we go with these ideas this is very
unique i love it just need to work on
the animation a little bit with the
rocket
that's so cool yeah i love this
very good stuff
watching netflix on the rocket that's
too much
not too much it's just it's hilarious i
love it
cool world
dig your world here
wow that's awesome
juanis
maybe that's how you say your
name right i gotta keep moving here
there's a lot
there's a lot to get into just missing
that character looking for that
character granted i have no character
guide either so i can't be saying much
but
pretty sweet dig it
and wrap door
chilling i like it wow those flowers
look really good
on the right there and the left that
looks nice
all right apologies i
have to keep moving forward here
okay interesting interesting
so it's a dude
in a time lapse
it's the same vehicle
but it looks like a miner it's a miner
or someone catching a ride
on a train maybe
and it's a story of them like
traveling through
it's their journey yeah it's that
infinite journey
nidhish that's cool i like the idea
mr ant yep
looking good
looking good i dig it
that's great i love your your clothes
man
that's really i'm not even getting close
to doing clothes
you're killing it that's great mr ant
oh mcfly
oh that's great
that's awesome
wow good design here on your car
marty mcfly doing his thing
that's awesome
very good mcfly that's good stuff
oh wow that's cool
oh snap okay okay okay so it's like a
pacific rim where you're controlling
the thing that's so cool
i love that idea
brilliant idea i love that yes it's good
to see these fresh ideas y'all
oh this is an adhesive v2
okay okay uh what else do we have
nice little underwater operation
supreme ruler of new vegas what do you
have i love the colors here
good sense of motion
fun character
pretty sweet pretty darn sweet
all right let's start i'm gonna start
getting a little further here
ollo what do you got
color grade is still a whip
looks cool you got a nice big world out
there
i like it's just a little fuzzy of
course still work in progress
ghost train
i like it i like it good stuff
moomron
oh yeah this is great
terrifying oh absolutely terrifying
oh and you also have the infinite
journeys
i like that logo that's a good logo
shoot
that's a good logo
i gotta admit that's solid
maybe a little too much on the on the
chromatic aberration here on the side
you
it's a little much it's a little much i
will say that it's a little much
but
you're killing it that's a great idea
very well executed as well
joshua whitney
oh no
casket oh brutal
brutal
wow
that's a heavy one
joshua
very good stuff keep it
up right sorry y'all i'm gonna keep
going i'm gonna keep scrolling here
couldn't resist making a full scene
ah this is the star wars one
very interesting
good stuff
good stuff d murano i love it i love it
um
dude this looks just like my friend
devon
what the heck
what was that
just a random hand coming out of nowhere
hard to tell what that is
akshit i i would love to tell more about
what that hand is
it is hard to tell what it is but
keep it up keep it up
nice okay okay
[Music]
the batman okay you got a nice
rock character i like it
suitcase made of rocks
leaving his rock village
yeah sweet okay you got a custom
character got a little custom world
i'm so curious is he leaving on purpose
or you get abandoned or what happened
i love it though
carter
what's going on here this is a cool uh
cool environment you got
nice and grungy i like your lighting
good stuff excited to see your character
oh this is cool yep i remember this one
good character here i don't know if
that's a downloaded character or what
but it's pretty
sweet walrus kingdom
oh yeah
yeah great idea
really really good idea
so these are lego dudes and who is this
i don't know who that is
but there's some lego guys hanging out i
like it very good idea very unique
one dead duck
nice working in after effects getting
your thing looking nice i love your
scene going black and white very bold
that's cool lighting
oh interesting okay so you went with
a different approach on this
very interesting
ah super creepy
metarox
metatrox rather
pizza not
oh brutal
brutal
it's a rough life
one aspiring artist
sweet okay i like your colors
very nice
that's pretty cool
i like your colors and your exterior
it's really cool
fled whammings
yeah good stuff
oh wow what is this
that's crazy peace
very nice
this this boat one
uh
dom f figgle huber
i'm excited to see this man i've been
waiting for it i think it has so much
potential
excited to see that finished
oh wow this is maxed out ton of detail
super cool
mc hammer
oh mitch mitch all right
done with modeling simulations and
animations started texturing the
foreground but there's still a lot to do
haven't worked on lights
just a quick hdri
dang dude this is nuts
that whole mast falls down in the
background wow that's gonna be so cool
dude i can't wait to see this with uh
dang with motion blur
with some atmosphere
dude that's going to be crazy
mitch mitch that's so good i can't wait
and mdk
nice
nice the little censorship there dig it
thank you
um this is crazy
little spline animation or uh
sweep animation there very interesting
i'm excited to see some like
to scale people down here in the bottom
that'll be cool and i wonder what your
background's gonna be
but yeah that's um that's about all the
time
we have for the
community works in progress
i think it's time to get back to
texturing this is the part of the stream
where i might get a little bit more
quiet and focus in on what i'm trying to
do here
because my voice
it's about about to be lost i can feel
it it's getting scratchy
but it's gonna be okay
because we're gonna be texturing now
and hanging out together while we work
on our art
shout outs y'all shout outs good times
all righty
all right
so what do we want to go to next
i could do i i want to do like a steal
some sort of steel for the chair perhaps
um
dez
i see it for the super chat
thank you brother
love the streams you're
such a chill dude really want to get
your feedback on my whip but my internet
isn't stable and uploads closed too soon
all good man just send me a dm on uh on
instagram i'll see what i can do see if
i can give you any feedback it's tough
though cause like i am judging it so
like i can't
give you too much feedback
but um
i appreciate you supporting and i
appreciate you working hard on your
render it's super cool keep it up
discord me a dm on
on discord see this is when
like i said my brain starts to go on the
last half of the stream so
bear with me y'all bear with me
okay
let's see what happens if i just pop
this uh material that we made on our
chair
see what that looks like
all right bucket seat
and let's try the
dirty paint
yeah so it's very dark i think it might
be a gamma issue
let's see 2.2
yeah okay okay
just gotta find the right balance of
like what's vibrant
not so dark
and i might
choose a different uh lighting condition
mm-hmm
that already looks a little bit better
yeah it's starting to look better
okay
so maybe we can make like a felt
material
or man maybe i should just get a chrome
like a chromed out situation
um we have this iron corroded from
grayscale gorilla
we could potentially use
let me see what this looks like if i
drop it on our
uh roll cage
or even on the bucket seat
and i'd probably want to scale up let's
see let's go ahead and scale up the uh
the actual pattern there the texture
that looks a little bit better based off
the reference
and that's not bad
okay so i'll probably go for something
like this
so let's make our own you know
we're here talking about materials
so let's do it um
let's get in close
okay
so let's make a
octane
uh metallic
material
and let's drop it on this chair
and let's go ahead and put it on all the
spots that we want it at least for this
view
so we got
symmetry know we probably be best is to
actually group all this stuff together
so that goes
here
um
i'll just call this chrome
and we'll just add
different bits here as needed
and i'll make a new camera
and put our camera tag on it because
that has like our color correction stuff
we'll really be able to tell like what
it's going to look like from that view
um so let's just go ahead and
make a new octane camera
and i'll pilot it and control drag
that in there
perfect and of course we'll adjust the
focus
awesome
all right so we have quite a few things
to do here
with this metal i think the first thing
to do
is add some
roughness
and i i will actually
do the roughness with
hmm
some monitor smudging
so like fingerprints hand prints that
kind of stuff i'll pipe that into the
roughness
and let's go ahead and just uh
get the projection and transform
tags on there
or nodes rather
set it to box projection and probably
point one
that looks pretty good
and then we'll add an octane gradient
because we want this to be a bit more
rough
a lot more rough actually so
let's take black up to white
it's somewhere in this range
you can also go to index
where you add index
ior mode that's what it is
[Music]
yeah this is why i actually like using
uh
the actual octane glossy
so let me just try that
octane glossy i'll drop it on
and i'll just copy all this over
i feel i just me personally have a bit
more control in the glossy i can make it
look like a chrome
[Music]
and i'll take that we'll go index here
uh
one
which turns it
why did it get so dark
interesting oh it's because
there we go
it was just on the wrong thing
or was it hold on
yeah we're good we're good
sweet and then i'll add some scratches
i have this weird like circular scratch
imperfection
that
might
be interesting for this i'll put it in
bump
and i'll set the projection
to box
and i'll scale it down
and i think we'll invert it
that doesn't look right that looks very
strange
a bunch of small scratches and we can
chill it out by going uh multiply
node and then a float node up in here
simple.2 perhaps
and let's try and get some dirt
up in the corners of this thing
um but let me let me adjust the
scratches first i think they could just
be tweaked a little bit more
that feels a bit more realistic to me
it just feels a little bright though
so maybe the specular can come down to
like point eight instead of one
if we do zero
yep okay we can take the diffuse to
black
and take that specular back up to 0.8
and it just darkens it a little bit
it's nice to have some control over that
and i can still chill out this uh
that bump there a little bit too
0.05
i want some grime in the corners of this
thing
so what we'll do is we'll call this uh
like our
we'll call this base metal
all right and then i'm going to make
a let's see
i bet you i can do this in here
so it's the specular that's that's what
it is so if i were to take a dirt node
in the specular
and basically say like
whatever's in the corners like this
goes to the actual color of our of our
material
which is black
and it's not shiny anymore so
i could do
instead of an all out situation like
we're doing
we could chill it out with a octane
gradient
and say whatever's black let's just take
to a gray
all right it's kind of like an ambient
occlusion almost
and we can take that
radius maybe to a three
and we could potentially
let's see
chill it out even a little more
and we could maybe even do like a grime
and a grunge kind of a thing so let's
take any one of these grunge
um let's see
i'm gonna try something crazy i'm gonna
try footprints and i know technically
this is not what it should be here but
i'm gonna break it and try and see if it
works
let's set that to float
save on our vram pipe that into specular
we'll go projection
oop
and transform
awesome it looks kind of sweet
let's invert it
interesting
oh that really dirties it up it gives an
interesting look
huh
that's very interesting
i wonder
if i give it some
an octane gradient
and just chill it out a lot
if there'd be a really interesting
texture inside of that
oh it's very interesting yeah i kind of
like that it's cool
maybe i'll take the scale up
to 0.2 or something
yeah so it's like a just a general kind
of grunge to it
very subtle
but we also want that so that's like our
overall right but we also want that in
just the cracks too
so
i'm going to
duplicate
this so we only want it to affect the
corners like right here right
let's throw a gradient in there again
and crunch it
just so we can really like
see what we're doing
and i want to combine these together i
think with a multiply or no i think it's
an ad
yeah that's just the corners now
which looks great
and i'll multiply these together to get
both
of uh
best of both worlds
so we have the overall
and we have the corner dirt as well
so we could chill out the corner dirt a
little bit
by bringing this back
awesome
and let's go one step further let's do
that top that top down dirt
right so we could do a
falloff node
all right so it's just coming top down
and then
we only want it to hit the areas
maybe on this dust wipe material right
so let's go ahead and change that to
float save on the vram
and then let's see
i'll combine these i believe with an ad
oh we got to do our thing here let's go
projection
transform
box
and
0.15
and we can invert
it and i don't like the way that looks
entirely so let's try and give it this
like
yeah there we go
sweet okay
and that will be
multiplied with
both of those there so we have
everything we got the corner dirt we
have the overall
and then we have the top down
smudging
so the on top dirt might be a bit much
so we can take a gradient
and
chill it out just a bit
and we can change this diffuse color to
our same color as our dirt
so what i can do is actually go to our
dirt here
grab the rgb spectrum
back to the base
metal and just pipe that into diffuse
and that'll actually
match up our color a little bit more
make things a bit more uniform now
it's a bit difficult to see
right because it's all chromed out
so
we could
just make it a little darker perhaps
just to cheat it a little bit
nice okay so that's going to be
distributed across
all of this stuff up here as well so i'm
going to go ahead and just
group all that stuff in
so that's gonna be this thing
this stuff
support
and the chair guard let's see chair
guard
sweet yeah all that stuff too
sweet now for the
padding it'd be cool to make like a felt
material but also at the same time
there might just be something we can
we can use um
so let's uh let's try
some grayscale gorilla
let's do their plus library and recently
they have uh
their tech products
this laptop fabric is pretty great
so i'm gonna try that
and i believe that goes on the padding
all right yeah you can tell obviously
our mapping is way off so let's go ahead
and fix that
[Music]
all right so that's going to be
all this stuff here but i don't know why
select these
and the base color right click
add a projection node and
add a transform node
little box projection on all this stuff
and the transform node can come to like
point
three maybe because we're going to be
viewing it from a distance
and just render regen
maybe a touch smaller
and then we kind of mess with the color
too
that metal still feels a bit bright to
me
and maybe it won't once we texture the
entire thing obviously we don't have
time to texture the entire thing on the
stream
[Music]
but maybe we can change this back to
black
then we take the specular
if we
white that out okay
let me go the other way around
that looks a little bit better to me
now with a felt i could go uh
more of an orange
let's see
let's give it a color correction node
and let's mess with the hue
almost looks like a leather or something
it's not the worst
but it matches with that like
that turquoise you know
and these screws
let's go ahead and work these
i just don't know where they are
let's try a black plastic
that looks pretty cool
i don't love it yet i think it's going
to take time for me to figure out what
colors i want to go with
but that's okay
and i'll probably need to pull more
reference
i figure these switches though
are gonna be
chromed out
the good thing about instances is that
um one it saves you on on memory but
also when you color
one object it'll color the rest so
let's try that base metal on the switch
and that'll get all the other switches
in the scene
i'll probably also get this uh
these different railing pieces
as well as this guy back here
awesome
now i'm gonna try here i'm gonna see
what this looks like if i just do this
turquoise throughout the entire thing
and i know i need stuff on this back
wall it's very empty right now
so there's definitely still a lot of
work to be done you know
ugh
hmm okay
wow so much for just the roughness
on this chair it's pretty crazy
i guess that's the specular rather let's
try and
fill this out a bit more
right not bad
uh edge
what's up man i see you
um
so you say you got a deep question what
is my ultimate goal
it's a good question man very good
question
um
what is my ultimate goal
i think my ultimate goal is to be able
to tell
uh to make movies
and to
do so
while also living a reasonable life not
super stressed out and crunched and
overworked
um
[Music]
i the reason i say movies is because
there's i have so many different
creative passions that uh
that come together
for a movie so writing
uh filming storytelling
doing 3d
um
working with music traveling
uh what else i don't know it all comes
together for a movie all of my hobbies
and usually i kind of write movies based
off of the hobbies i enjoy anyway it
also allows me to be with my friends and
family and work hard on something
together and be able to put something
out that we can be proud of in the end
so that's kind of my ultimate goal to be
able to do that
and also like you know have a family and
not
have to sacrifice one over the other you
know i want to be able to find a nice
balance i think balance is also another
ultimate goal of mine to constantly be
balanced and um
and to just stay happy you know
so
that
i don't know right now that's my
ultimate goal for sure i'm sure there's
some other ones i'm sure things will
come up later uh
you know as i continue living life
but um
yeah that's a good question man i
appreciate that thank you
uh
okay
where are we at
yeah we got a chair here i'm not super
happy with this chair right now but it's
all right
i know that uh i'll just have to keep
working on it
i'm just curious what it's to look like
if i
put this texture on
the dashboard here
oh wow
very interesting i don't love it
but that's okay
because i'm still working on it
i basically just need to stare at this
for a very long time
that's kind of it you know
you just gotta stare at it for a long
time
figure out how you want it to look you
gotta find your reference i'm failing to
find reference right now like
there is mad max
i think this this looks nice
i would like to go for something like
this
it's probably more of a muted version of
what i'm doing
um
this is cool maybe for some stuff but
not everything
this is also a cool vibe too
i think i just need more things in my
scene i need to keep modeling
that's the tricky part
yeah this is cool too
certainly
but i like this grunginess
with everything
i don't want to overdo it that's for
sure i need to go in and add all the
writing here that's going to take
forever
uh what else
you know you see this is very clean
there's a very clean look right here
which i i'm not really going for i want
to be more of a dusty
dirty kind of thing like like this
this is cool
there's a lot of stuff everywhere though
i think it just comes down to more
detail it needs more detail
this is beautiful too
great lighting
this isn't a bad reference
as well actually the tan and the green
it's definitely a military kind of vibe
obviously you have all the dirty
imperfections up here
which is super cool
and i might try and work something like
this into the
padding could be interesting
we had that olive drab with the black
and the tan is such a good look
it's kind of doing it here you know
it's very dirty see these edges super
dirty so i might might work that a
little bit i just have to tweak it but
everything i everything i did here when
i set up that master material
that's basically it you know once you
set that up it's just a matter of
choosing your colors and figuring out
where you want your stuff to go i always
have like a metal that i use i have a
painted metal scratch metal
and a rubber that's kind of what i built
out for
the boston dynamics videos when i
textured that robot
that's basically the materials i had you
know
um and it all comes down to just placing
it placing them in ways
that make it
look like you got a lot of stuff going
on in your scene so
yeah i just need to work on it i got to
keep going let's undock this
and we could also change our lighting
too
let me see if i can
do a little something there perhaps
so
so
and the lighting will definitely change
too as we get the character in there and
i fill out the scene a little bit more
yeah there's definitely part of me
that's like
i'm at
the point here where i'm kind of bummed
with my scene
and
i i know that i just have to continue
and it's gonna be better but right now
it doesn't feel special it feels average
it feels clean
uh it feels
empty but
that's okay
i'm gonna keep at it i'm gonna keep at
it
so i don't know if y'all have any
questions but i'll hang out with y'all
for the next five minutes i think i'm
gonna call it here
but um
yeah let's hang out for five minutes and
and uh see how you guys are doing thank
you so much for for hopping in with me
uh saipo says take take a look at lauren
sega sunset okay what is that
that's a song
oh cool cool
i'll definitely check this out this
looks totally up my alley
yes
lauren sega sunset it's like a anime
music video
okay i'm down for that 100
100
mdk yeah man it's annoying when you
plateau on a scene
and you gotta push through it it's a
tough one
but that's where we're at right now
and it comes down to me for a reference
i just gotta keep i gotta find my
references and i gotta
i gotta match the reference build it out
like the reference um
and just keep tweaking all the way until
the day and to the last
hour
uh but be careful with it obviously
because
you know you guys want to get your stuff
in
you want to submit in time you don't
want it to be late i would hate for
y'all to have your stuff be late
but we have a
super chat from hunter hall i appreciate
you man uh
clint hope all is well it's hunter from
jpl i know i know hunter hall i got you
uh sent you a dm on ig about a cool mini
series on youtube check out the back
rooms oh yeah dude the back rooms is
great
that guy
is like killing it it's a perfect mix of
storytelling and cgi a perfect mix i
actually posted it in uh
in uh inspiration on the
discord because it was just so freaking
good
uh but yeah check it out it's called the
back rooms it's just
probably some kid in blender like
just telling a story in a really really
cool way it's a perfect use of
storytelling and blender combined
together so well done
seriously it's incredible hunter i
really appreciate the super chat man
thank you so much for that
way to top it off at the end here man
it's awesome of you thank you so much
um what else just at punisher me here
and i will uh
i will see what's going on
um
oh we got some japanese hair up in the
chat
i recognize
a couple of those things tokyo
uh
tokyo nin
i don't know that symbol i don't know
this symbol is that
like
nihongo
or nihonjin maybe you're japanese you're
from tokyo
you live in tokyo
um
that's sweet
uh i'm proud i've been practicing my
japanese hero is that what that says
who knows who knows i could i could
practice this stuff all day i'm a good
i'm a freaking
huge obviously as you can tell from my
background guys i'm a fan
um
you should do a vfx artist react to the
back rooms that's up to them hunter you
know that that's up to the guys
for sure
um
you know and they they call me every
once in a while and they have me on
it needs mirror dice yeah i thought of a
little mirror situation but i don't have
like a clear
a rearview mirror wouldn't make sense
just because you can't see what's behind
you in this ship but i'm gonna add some
dangly stuff there's a bunch of me like
personal dangly stuff
um
little trinkets and whatnot that are
gonna be affected by the g-forces so
that'll be cool
uh jack what's up dude
uh you went and filmed yourself like a
madman acting out all the parts in your
scene to get the animation better that's
what's up man that'll make it so much
better get that reference for sure
sir diff do i use substance painter for
texturing some of the stuff you did
today would have probably been easier
yeah i agree
it is the top is the top program on my
list to learn
so
maybe later this year you'll see me
streaming
in substance painter i hope to be doing
it because
yeah it'll save me a ton of time
i i need to learn it i definitely need
to learn it
uh jed how do i use a pen for everything
what are the benefits of using a pen
tablet in general workspace and not just
for sculpting um
i don't know i just got used to it to be
honest like um
i do everything with a pen except play
video games on my computer which is very
rare when i play video games on my
computer
because i'm on my computer all the time
so i just try and
uh you know that's why i love my switch
i'll get out i'll take my switch or i'll
just go to the go to the couch and play
some playstation or something
but
yeah you get used to it you get used to
it for sure you know
it's not that big of a deal and the
benefit of it for me is just the fact
that
my wrist never gets tired when i use
this for hours
with a mouse my wrist will get tired and
it has to do with your bones this way
your your forearm
bones there's two bones here running
down the length of your forearm and
when you turn it to use a mouse they're
twisted
but then uh there's some mouse's
ergonomic mouses that are like
you know these like big brick looking
things i've tried them but at the end of
the day i just love this pen it has like
a bunch of different buttons on it i can
draw with it that's like the biggest
thing the ergonomic mouse can't draw
with it this you can draw with so i like
having as few things as possible and the
wacom tablets definitely come in handy
which as you all know the intuos pro
tablets are part of the infinite
journeys prize pool for third place and
up
um so that'll be pretty sweet
scotty boy blue
thank you sir i appreciate that super
chat that's very very kind of you not
even a a message just a nice little
super chat thank you so much that is
amazing
i appreciate the support if you have a
question feel free to add me
here um have i played sifu yes i'm
playing it right now i'm on stage four
it is ridiculously hard uh it's so good
oh my god it's such a masterpiece of a
game i'm probably gonna go get some
pizza and then play sifu after this it's
gonna be sick
yeah the game's incredible it's like a
it's like the raid but as like a
cel-shaded low-poly kind of video game
so good
oh my god hunter hall dude
hats off to you dude
much appreciated
god dang
thank you so much for that super chat
hope uh you have a great rest of the
weekend dude you as well my goodness
have a good one man um
shout outs to you it's always good to
see you here
i've bumped into you twice here um
and it's always it's always a it's
always a treat dude it's always a treat
to see someone bump into someone you
recognize and
and uh i just hope you're having a good
one i'm probably not making too much
sense here because we're at the end of a
stream and my brain cells are like
diminished at this point i hadn't had
any water
um melanie yo what's up melody hey good
to see you thank you for the support
that's amazing
um how was my week my week was pretty
darn good what did i do this week i
watched apocalypse now for the first
time last night that was a freaking
crazy movie i can't believe that movie
was uh
that they did they finished that movie
have you ever seen apocalypse now you
know what i'm talking about
i
i'm speechless speechless
crazy absolutely insane i still prefer
saving private ryan but apocalypse now
was nuts
what did i do i worked on my scene
i got some writing done i got some
workouts in
um
[Music]
what else i got to visit my good friend
uh dave david ariev
his
wife
was in an nft gallery like a live in
person nft gallery
uh last night so i went down and visited
them that was cool
um other than that you know just playing
a little bit of a
sifu on the ps4
and i'll be cooking tonight so i
appreciate you melanie thank you so much
and hunter thank you again brother i
really appreciate that man
that's awesome
brandon you're on level three level
three's tough level two was the hardest
for me the club was the hardest
that was ridiculous
uh eggman am i getting a stream deck man
i've had a stream deck for ages i'm
looking at it right here it's great
it's very very handy
what else um
victor you got some inspiration for us
say hey uh progress no matter
how much you like what you've got
sorry hold on no matter how much you
like
what you've made it is still progress
keep up the great work thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much
that is awesome man
sweet
dkk yo
what's up dude
thanks for the super chat
these europe time zones you are late
all good man
uh oh sorry dkk that's not your name
that is the currency qualbeck
cool
goldberg i don't know how to pronounce
that uh
but i tried sorry mom my brain cells are
diminishing by the minute the more i
talk i appreciate the super chat though
thank you very much
this live stream will be up
for until the end of time so you will
always have a chance to watch it
um
no a steam deck not a stream deck a
steam deck
yeah i think i want to get one for uh
eldon ring
that way i can play
i don't have to buy ps5 for it and i can
you know
play it from the couch so that'll be
pretty sweet
any last
minute questions y'all
i got like one more minute
i'm dying
my brain sells
i'm fading y'all i'm fading
what made me choose octane over redshift
um cause ren was using octane and he
taught me how to use it and he showed me
all the tutorials that i needed to
to watch
to learn octane david arya of being like
the main dude i learned octane through
david
arya uh mainly through him yeah
holding it down
ah papaxo hey i'm excited to see how
your your uh 2d
submission is going you said you met the
moderators yesterday on the voice
discord and gotta say it's such a great
and fun community yes that makes me so
happy that makes me so so happy
the modern the moderators are all
incredible very kind people
and uh everyone here in the community is
very supportive so it's super cool to
hear man i'm glad that uh that you had
that experience
all right what else
edge thank you thanks for tuning in man
i appreciate you
yes we're both we're both on those final
stretch man we gotta get it done
we gotta get it done
how do you pronounce punisher
all right that's that's
answering a question at the same time
um cheers from austria manuel
good stuff
um
melanie
am i writing a script or a book i am
writing a script a movie script an hour
and a half long movie script
uh it's the first time i've ever done it
it's the first time i've ever done a
full hour and a half long script
so it is quite
the amount of work it's taking months
it's going to take months maybe half a
year maybe a full year who knows
but i hope to be filming next year
and i can't wait to tell you all more
about it it's going to be sweet
dalek drummer how long does the discount
code last i'll have it go for the day
i'll pull it off here after the day
right now i got 50 off
my uh all my textures
on the gum road right so
uh the link is in the description got a
little discount code for y'all in the
description 50 off my endless concrete
textures
um and 50 off my surface imperfections
as well so get them while you can while
they're 50 off they'll help you texture
your scenes here make them look really
nice if you're using concrete or if
you're trying to dirty up your stuff
with surface imperfections
shout outs just to the end of the day
just for y'all just for y'all
have i watched the olympics though i
have not watched the olympics
melanie i'm excited for this movie as
well i can't wait for y'all to watch it
what's my target budget goodness um
honestly i think like three to five
million it's probably gonna be a three
to five million dollar movie
how i'm gonna get that money i have no
idea but we'll figure it out
and it's gonna be um it's gonna be a
journey and i'm gonna i'm i'm gonna
document the whole process
all of the all the stuff i learned just
like i'm learning here in 3d i'm going
to film all of it and make videos on
like what i'm learning when i'm making
this movie um so stuff on set
writing it
actually budgeting it out like
everything
i'm gonna guide you all through it so if
you all wanna make a movie of your own
you'll get an idea of how it's gonna go
down so that's gonna be sweet
no void will you stop ignoring my
questions every stream well i don't
that's the only question i've seen dude
i don't know what other question you
have other than that
uh paul
what's up paul great stream as always
have a great week and you as well man
good luck with your render i'm excited
to see it
yeah crowdfunding definitely i thought
of uh crowdfunding as a way
to
to fund a bit of it i don't know if i
could crowdfund three to five million
that's a lot of money
we'll see we'll see what we can do i
haven't even thought about budgeting yet
just because i'm focused on writing
that's the hardest part for me
so i'll get through that and i'll worry
about it later
brand doom do have plans in the future
to start a studio and hire artists and
create a team or do you plan to work
solo you know i have no idea
um maybe there's a future where i'm
going to like need to keep hiring people
um i'm definitely going to need to hire
people for this movie
so maybe it'll be a production studio or
something there but we'll see you know
in time i'm kind of taking it one step
at a time here so
things about it y'all
i think that is about it
yo i really appreciate you thank you so
much
you guys have a good one good luck on
the rest of your art
and um
yeah you'll have one more week we got
one more one more week together last
week is the uh or sorry next week is the
last stream
and then we're gonna go on to the live
judging stream in uh march i think march
4th or march 5th it's that saturday
and that'll be the
the last time i stream in march because
i'm just gonna be posting montages y'all
top 100s
all renders montages and then we go back
to regular schedule in april
and may and and on and on until we do
our next community challenge which will
be sometime
later this year um
so yeah it'll go back to a stream one
stream per month and one like pre-edited
video per month the first one coming up
i think in april we're gonna do a live
stream with as many of the top five
winners as possible we're going to have
them on and just talk about their scene
together
that'll be
a live stream in april and then i'm
going to do a whole breakdown on how i
made my scene here
for those of you um who want more of a
packaged kind of 15-minute version
of how i did my entire scene i still
have a lot of work to do
and um i'm kind of writing the video as
i'm creating this
so different little tips and tricks on
i kind of had to relearn c4d for this
you know
so i have little tips and tricks there
um i'm gonna have stuff on modeling
there'll be stuff on texturing of course
there'll be stuff on uh motion capture
which i'll be doing with a rococo suit
a whole bunch of different stuff
from start to finish on this entire
scene here
so that'll be in april as well
but y'all
good times
um carter am i going to be the only one
judging top 100 nope i'm going to get
some guest judges to come on
which will be uh probably now it's the
week of that uh
that that that judging live stream
brandon i appreciate you man thank you
so much
dominic you have a great rest of your
day as well thank you for joining
uh and yeah visual
thanks for the reminder we got another
big announcement
coming here on the uh two weeks from now
two weeks from now we got a nice
announcement for y'all it's just gonna
help everyone
make some more uh make cooler art
and get inspired to make more art that's
basically what we're doing so stay tuned
for that it's gonna be awesome
but y'all
i'm beat it's time to get some pizza
it's time to play some video games
and i'll see you all next week thank you
thank you so much
until next time
i don't know
good luck
see you guys
[Music]
so
[Music]
you